هذه هي الرحله الثانيه الصينيه التي تغادر
من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده الى
العاصمه الصينيه بعدما كان على متن الرحله
الاولى 347 مواطن مما تم مما تم ممن تم
اجلائهم من السودان من قبل السلطات
السعوديه هذه هي الرحله الثانيه التي
تغادر مدينه جده وعلامتها
145 مواطن صيني وكانوا قد وصلوا الى مدينه
جده بعد ان تم اجلائهم من السودان خلال
اليومين الماضيه وبعد ذلك تم منحهم
التاشيره استثنائيه لمده شهر ولكن عملت
السفاره الصينيه في السعوديه على التعجيل
او التسريع في انهاء اجراءات السفر لهؤلاء
الرعايه الذين قدموا من بناء بورت سودان
الى مدينه جده عبر السفن البحريه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه خلال اليومين
الماضيه كان في عدد من الممثلين عدد
من الممثلين وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
وكذلك السفير الصيني ها هم اليوم او ها هي
دفعه الثانيه من الرعايه الصينيين يغادرون
مدينه جده من المتوقع انه سوف سوف تكون
هنالك رحله ثالثه كذلك على متنها رعايه من
من الصين ايضا المتوقع انه سوف تحمل هذه
الطائره
اعداد كبيره في المره القادمه انه تم
تخصيص طائره بوينج تربل السفن التابعه
للخطوط الصينيه هي الطائره المخصصه لنقل
الاعداد او الرعايه من مدينه جده عبر مطار
الملكه عبد العزيز الدولي بجده نتحدث ان
هذه هي الطائره تعود مجددا لنقل الرعايه
بعدما نقلت 347 مواطن صيني ها هي اليوم
تستعد للاقلاع الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين
وعلى متنها 145
مواطن صيني عمليات المغادره من مدينه جديه
مستمره في الساعات الماضيه كان قد رصدنا
مغادره
مواطن هندي ايضا المتوقع خلال الساعه
القادمه تغادر ايضا جنسيات اخرى ومختلفه
من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده
وهذه عمليه الاجلاء مستمره بعد ان تم
اجلائهم من ميناء بورت السودان الى مدينه
جده عبر قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه او حتى
عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي او حتى جوا عبر
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجوي فيما يتعلق
باستمرار عمليات الاجلام
الى مدينه جده من المتوقع ساعات في ساعات
الظهر اليوم ان تصل رحله اجلاء مدنيه من
ميناء بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده على متنها اعداد او ارقام
تصل او تلامس الالفين شخص باختلاف
جنسياتهم نعم ايضا كما نشاهد مشاعر الفرح
والامتنان والتقدير على وجوه هؤلاء
الرعايه بعد سوف يستعدوا لمغادره جده بعد
ان استقبلته السعوديه وقامت بتوفير كافه
الخدمات اللازمه لهم من ناحيه انهاء
السرعه في انهاء الاجراءات ومنحهم تاشيره
استثنائيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات